this man is serious no one expected this
to happen
you'd be arriving at the Royal courts of
Justice today in his court case against
the Daily Mail we thought it was on the
west coast of the United States with his
family that is not the case uh within
the last few minutes Prince Harry has
arrived at the high court here in London
you can tell he's serious about this one
let's just listen
sorry
what are you hoping to achieve sir was
the question to Prince Harry he uh has
taken the associated newspapers which
prints The Daily Mail to court over
alleged phone hacking along with others
including Sir Elton John uh Elizabeth
Hurley and the like
um we're not sure where the others are
and we weren't expecting Prince Harry to
turn up and this is uh one of four cases
I believe that we are likely to see
according to Katie uh Spencer between
now and June uh and Prince Harry leaving
his family behind presumably on the west
coast of the United States as he arrives
at the high court just ahead of
proceedings this morning Goodness Me